foreign
so perhaps we could begin with just a
brief
discussion doesn't have to be brief
about depression and perhaps what people
underestimate don't appreciate about
depression what you have
come to realize perhaps as a clinician
over many decades just to set the table
as it were for our discussion of
different treatments comparisons
ketamine Etc I think that people
think that depression is like having a
bad day
and
everybody's had a bad day
and everybody's had a few bad days
and
and I think
that some of the confusion about
depression
has to do with the way in which we use
throw depression around as a term like
I spilled my coffee and I'm depressed
about that now yeah that is a
disappointment right but that kind of
experience isn't what we're talking
about when we talk about depression when
we talk about depression is more about
the experience that you're talking about
the way that depression can be a
pervasive
mode of being that invades every aspect
of one's life and experience of the
world it affects the pattern of your
thinking in other words instead of as
you say instead of seeing the world as a
mixture of risk and opportunity
you see the negative in everything that
you engage
it affects the way you make judgments
instead of being able to make judgments
based on reasonable risk reward kinds of
decisions everything's colored by the
negativity
what people often don't appreciate about
depression is that it goes beyond
sadness for many people
it can be a complete
blunting of emotional experience and
people describe sometimes the loss of
feeling
one of the people that we treated with
ketamine said that she was just amazed
to have feelings again after her
depression began to lift people often
describe feeling blue when they're
depressed because the contrasts in the
world their visual experience of the
world is as if the the normal contrasts
are blunted and and colors seem duller
and and
things that are exciting and rewarding
seem blander and
a kind of sapping of lice essence
this kind of depression is associated
with a loss of energy a loss of
concentration difficulty sleeping waking
up early in the morning tossing and
turning in difficulty relaxing and
feeling comfortable being overcome with
pervasive
intrusive
recurring thoughts on negative things
like
I'm a terrible person I let people down
over and over and over ruminating on
these negative
horrible ideas and
I mentioned a sapping of energy
loss of appetite decreased interest in
activities a kind of withdrawal this
state was deemed by the Greek
Hippocratic doctors as
as a kind of fundamental negative mode
of being that they thought was connected
to black bile which in Greek
had the name melon for black colea for
bile and then has been known as
Melancholia or black melancholic
depression ever since and there's
another kind of depression that we also
see which is people who have the
capacity
to see good and bad but who cannot
constrain the way in which they react
so
something good happens they can
react in a normal way to it but
something bad happens to them and they
spiral downward in a very negative way
out of beyond their control to Despair
and hopelessness and extreme distress
that is not the typical profile of
traditional melancholic depression but
it's a kind of reactive depression so
that there are one of the things that we
appreciate about depression is that can
be a very heterogeneous things that
there's a whole array of different kinds
of depression
and we're just at the early stages of
sorting that out but one thing that's
really important
for people to understand that they often
don't understand is the medical part of
depression and when I say medical part
is that that we understand
yes medical depression is a state of
emotional experience and yes it's a
altered way of brain function
but it's a brain function of an embodied
brain in other words depression is a
state that affects your entire body
medical factors like inflammatory
processes in the body related to obesity
cardiac disease arthritis
asthma a variety of things that cause
inflammation in the body increase your
risk for depression
and if you have depression it makes
inflammation worse
and that means it makes all of those
medical illnesses where inflammation is
a process worse and so that if you have
untreated depression on average
it shortens your life not by Suicide
it still shortens your life by about
five years and if you have depression in
the context of medical illnesses it
makes the medical outcomes worse not
only the psychological outcomes but the
medical outcomes worse So Meta
depression is a disorder of the spirit
if you will the brain but also the whole
body and and that's one of the reasons
why number one
it's one of the most disabling
conditions that we have in the world
and two it's from a medical point of
view it's also urgently important that
people are treating their depression